and then even the other people in that
group oh is Melania coming over oh yeah
I don't know if that's her okay uh
Molina just joined us what were we
talking about was it interesting you
were saying that you were going to talk
to Elon about getting at Omni Destiny
the verified Twitter account on band I
said that so that sounds like a lot
that's so gracious of me I can't even
believe you would do that for me and
then you admitted that you tried to
evade the band multiple times which I'm
sure would be very uh looked upon you
know I heard that in Norway in their
prison system they don't actually punish
you for trying to escape jail because
that's like the natural human thing to
do hug you what do they I don't know if
they but they don't punch you because of
course you're trying to be free that's
all I'm trying to be on Twitter I'm just
trying to be free well that's the
natural human yeah that's the natural
hair of course it's the benefit you're
not a destructive force you're just no
I'm a positive I'm a Force for good
that's why all my accounts only get
banned for bad news I don't get banned
for doing bad things Progressive show
I'm like far left I love like
Progressive classes this is what you
criticize Hassan for being
I show them from a place of first
principles not from a Mindless AI
echoing kind of thing you know okay see
your free thinking bot yeah exactly all
right cool uh well I'm sure we'll return
to some politics that was beautiful uh
Malia can you tell us about yourself you
also a fellow streamer
your story I stream and I started
streaming because I met him basically
basically kind of but I don't do the
politics I do like travels or talk about
relationships talk to my audience
basically you're from that part of the
world right Sweden yeah exactly so did
you escape from prison and they didn't
that was Norway that's different I
actually really I've been to Sweden a
bunch of times I love it there's a tech
sector there that's really like
flourishing where did you go which city
I went to Stockholm I think I gave a few
lectures there there's a vibrant Tech
sector it was cool and people are super
nice
yeah we're friendly we're not like very
deep like we don't really have much deep
conversation it's like a meta oh there's
not many intellectuals that come from
Sweden we don't really speak very highly
ourselves we kind of like just chill all
the time we don't make a scene we don't
we're just like there's uh you know do
you know what the name for that is
there's a specific name for it yeah the
login yeah you have to log in yeah oh
there's a philosophy behind it when
you're part of like Sweden or Norway you
like you don't talk too highly of
yourself because it's kind of like rude
like think of like America except the
exact opposite you don't even really
want to like you don't want to make
yourself into a victim too much you
don't want to be too much of anything
you're just like sticking to the to the
group don't make a big scene about
yourself
but that said you came here and you were
you put yourself in front of the camera
and became a streamer do you understand
how weird that is for my friends in
Sweden I just didn't talk about myself
and just like make a big deal about
myself for hours every day was that like
terrifying did you have anxiety about
that no because I don't see them but
then I come back and I'm like oh
so what do you feel like when you're
actually streaming you feel like you're
just alone in a room
um one-on-one type no I see I see Chad
I'm thinking oh they're like little
fairies they're not really real they're
just like out there I don't know what
they look like I just see little names
and they're just cute colors you know
you're talking to little fairies is that
how you feel about chat they're demons
for me they're demons okay my annivers
are they so is Chad a source of stress
or happiness like is there no for me
that's a source of happiness I've been
very intentional with like the
construction of my community so I'm
really happy with where it's at